Oh Walter what happened here little
buddy were you trying to attack a fence
and you hurt your little baby foot you
don't want to talk about it do you would
you rather go walkies just hide you go
walkies oh you're so sad you don't even
want to go walkies
come on little buddy come on now buddy
yeah I think that's what happened
Walter was trying to attack a dog on the
other side of a fence it's been a rough
weekend but a couple things happen that
we're kind of go this goddamn vlog but
I'm going to you're only one reason
because it's a it's a lifestyle video
right Walter this weekend was a rough
one uh we're here at an undisclosed
private location and we're ready to see
some [ __ ] fireworks man where the
[ __ ] are they yeah okay this is the most
[ __ ] shittiest half-assed fireworks
video I've ever seen
makes me want to blow myself up using
the GoPro because when I was strapping
the surfboards to the roof of my car
I left my vlogging camera right there
and then I got in and it [ __ ] fell
off we're going surfing anyway whatever
so I leave anything [ __ ] nuts up
there god damn it recording
[Music]